when candidates say we want to admit
three-year-old orphans that's political
posturing when individuals say that we
should have a religious test and that
only Christians proven Christians should
be admitted that's offensive and
contrary to American values
I cannot think of a more potent
recruitment tool for ISIL then some of
the rhetoric that's been coming out of
here at during the course of this debate
and I would add by the way these are the
same folks often times who suggest that
they're so tough that just talking to
Putin are staring down ISIL or using
some additional rhetoric somehow is
going to solve the problems out there
but apparently they're scared of widows
and orphans coming into the United
States of America as part of our
tradition of compassion
at first they were worried about the
press being too tough on them during
debates now they're worried about
three-year-old orphans
that doesn't sound very tough to me
you